The joe rogan experience.
Well,
the reason you key I and shout is to
create intrabdominal pressure so you can
stabilize the system.
Maybe you not me.
You sound like you use magic bro.
When I'm key I a you throw fireballs,
the shrine in my mind.
So the third thing is that we create,
we screw the feet into the ground,
right?
This torsion of kind of
creating grip through the,
through the like the same sort of grip
you go towards no externally rotate,
right?
That's right.
Wax On.
Wax Off was teaching what Steven Seagal
always throws in the same position,
screwing a light bulb
minutes the way he runs on,
look at the way he runs.
You ever see him run?
That's a perfect example.
Pull up Steven Seagal running.
Let's see.
It's a perfect example of see if Kelly
can fix the way Steven Seagal runs and
this is no back to the Stevens.
Augustine's number to call is an excellent
martial artist and he's very good at
Ikea.
I mean he was one of the first Japanese
Americans rather to teach in Japan.
This right had a
legitimate respected Dojo.
So now Kido is,
has they figured out to throw people,
you're wining the shoulder
up into what position?
This extra.
Yeah,
and then you have to tremendous
amount of power with that.
US wells with judo.
Same position that's rolled.
Getting getting yourself in a position.
We'll get him running.
Tell,
tell me what's wrong here.
Everything is wrong.
He has a lot wrong.
They're right.
Ge taught him how to run the Louis.
He's,
he's got to look at this.
Look how he's running.
Actually,
you know,
it's not bad.
He's running on the ball of his foot.
I've seen why worse.
Let's back now he's getting older.
He's getting over extended.
Oh,
you got it.
Yeah.
And that this is different.
This is this.
This is a,
this is the guy who started,
gets stiff and fly around and
play a little too much music.
Everybody talks shit about him.
But the dude,
he's a bad ass.
Legitimate martial artists.
He knows a lot about Marshall.
I wanted to be a navy seal cook.
If after I saw where this police don't
Machita legitimately takes advice from
that guy.
Everybody thinks it's bullshit and they
think I'm just trolling Lubick Liotta
Machita respects that guy enough to take
instruction from him and to listen to
him talk.
Why?
Why wouldn't,
I mean he figured a lot
things out the keys.
A lot of us don't have sort of the Meta
cognition where I want to see if he runs
on his toes though.
I need to see that ball of the foot.
So let's,
let's take a couple of conversations
with all the foot is good ball.
Let's be clear.
Let's see how he's running.
There was either running,
no,
we're not running.
He'll first man guys breast out.
He's hitting.
He'll first.
No Way.
That's actually not
gonna stop that running.
Okay,
look,
it's crazy.
That guy is flat footed.
When he's landing,
he is running terrible and
your foot flat footed is okay.
What's not okay?
Ball of the foot strikes first.
That's not okay.
That's okay.
Oh,
that's,
there's some variation
that what he's doing.
Well,
it's hard to tell.
I'm talking,
it's not hard to tell him.
He's moving really fast.
I'm talking shit.
I mean it might have been all the foot.
Here's what,
here's what I would think.
That's less efficient.
What's going on now?
What's all that about?
Unstable.
Unstable,
so unstable.
And that's what he's,
he's looking for.
He's,
that's how we use this
as like Quito though.
He's all,
he's like with like,
oh,
so you mean practice makes permanent?
This is that a whole bunch.
And that's the only way.
So even when he runs,
he's got that sort of whipping
motion going on when his arms,
it kind of makes sense.
So totally.
We teach people to run.
We say,
hey,
pretend like you're grabbing two chips.
Right?
Put your shoulders in this position.
This extra rotated position
makes you shoulder stable.
It creates the building in the head.
What you'll see is that
people are on your chips,
man.
Chips.
Like you have two potentials.
Don't cross the chips.
Two of them.
Imagine that you're grabbing
something else and you don't.
You want to be gentle.
Right?
Right.
Can you say,
why would you say my name is Coco?
I don't understand.
Like pull your elbows tight.
No,
this is,
this is how you should be running.
You're just holding onto the ships.
This is how you'd run
a protect those checks.
So where,
where was his hands going?
Across his body.
So how much force is he given away?
All of that.
So my hands coming across,
I got to stop that.
It's a heavy load.
I want to minimize that.
When you see kids running
with their elbows out,
right.
Like RTD too.
You're right.
That's a test.
That's c three Po runs with his arms out.
Yeah.
What is the r two d two doesn't have arms.
I'm just letting you talk to him.
All right,
I'll try it.
See if you're here to stay in your here.
I'm fine.
Still rewinding.
You were talking about
squeezing that butt early.
We're coming back.
Okay.
Yes.